anywhere you go like if you do something
about some candy there's gonna be
somebody at your next camp that knows
what she did yeah so I was playing poker
and it's like you shouldn't really be
gambling while you're locked up if
you're trying to stay out of trouble and
show like that cuz it was pretty much it
was pretty much me like a bunch of black
dudes [ __ ] gambling all the time and
like they called me the great white hope
what they called me the great white hope
because like I'm not [ __ ] a lot of a
lot of white dudes that go into prison
are [ __ ] lame and green as [ __ ] like
our [ __ ] big-time [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
and like I wasn't and I [ __ ] knew how
to gamble and I'm not [ __ ] stupid
so I remember one time we're gambling
it's just with this this big-ass [ __ ]
this big has dude from Tampa he calls me
a [ __ ] one day at the poker table he
said go get some more money broke [ __ ]
and I told him don't you [ __ ] does I
don't call me a [ __ ] [ __ ] and he
goes all right [ __ ] I go right I took
all the chips I had and I threw it in
his face
and he did you tell him get there and
that's like a part of the pod to where
they can't see you fight where the guard
station can't really see you so I'm like
alright well I thought I was gonna get
this [ __ ] beat out of me so I was like
guys do was that big ball yeah it was
bigger than me but he was just he's a
big [ __ ] goofball anyway well we ever
being friends like after being at
different camps and all that so uh so we
were fighting we're lined up and you
like you fight like down this wall so he
like kind of kept running from me like
backing up and it's like I just want to
fight just get this [ __ ] [ __ ] over
with so uh I ended up like hitting on
one good time and he was like oh I'm
done I'll go alright cuz that's how I am
like fighting with me is win or lose I'm
cool after man like I got it off my
chest right like I don't I don't give a
[ __ ] if I get beat up cuz if you have
not gettin beat up in your life you have
not fought anybody worth fighting you
know I mean yeah so a lot but after that
I had to stay up for three [ __ ] that
was a good
if you if you have never gotten beat up
in your life that's an epic clue you
have never fought anybody worth fighting
because you're picking and choosing weak
people to fight right yeah man that's
that's a whole prison thing is people
prey on the weak yeah it's basically
what I'm getting into so but after that
I mean it says he was from the guy I
fought was from Tampa and there happened
to be like like four other dudes from
his neighborhood in there and for him to
stop against the white boy it was a that
was a big whole [ __ ] thing so I had to
stay up for three days straight so I did
not get my [ __ ] head bashed in with a
lock just to watch your back and said
well no because a lot of time because
people it's it's people are [ __ ] are
people are scared they act tough but
they're [ __ ] scared yeah so well I've
waked up I've waking up in the middle of
the night when it when I was in there
and people will take your their belt and
put it on because we have like the
schoolmaster locks to put on our yeah I
drawers to like our commissary and all
that so but like I wake it up i waking
up at 3:00 in the morning to like I do
next means getting his [ __ ] head
bashed in with a lot yeah so but it's
like all I'm hearing for like like it's
all lights out it's probably like
midnight now and then I'm just like oh
you let that cracker get over on you put
that cracker get over on you and I'm
like okay cool well I'm gonna be up for
foot three [ __ ] days so I'm like
trying to read books and I'm just like
I'm pretty much just like eating instant
coffee trying to like stay awake it's
just like it's like the worst feeling
because you're just waiting for Italian
because right you're what you're
generating so because a lot of people I
would say [ __ ] 90% of people in
prison are [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah that
they would wait and sneak up on you or
way to your sleep and when you say this
guy below you guy just got his head
bashed in like yeah he'd survive oh yeah
he survived yeah yeah yeah they're
killed like um I never saw anybody get
killed I mean I've seen okay so like
[ __ ] you see in the movies and those
shows it happens it doesn't happen every
[ __ ] day like I've been I've been 20
feet away from like these guys they were
chasing this guy around and he when he
swung I was like wow he [ __ ] it's
like a big
you're right but I'm like why the [ __ ]
he punched him like that I go oh my god
he's stabbing them these two these two
guys are stabbing the [ __ ] out of this
dude but I'm like those guys hit like
[ __ ] [ __ ] right but I'm like oh [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] stabbing over but I'm
like 20 feet away but it's like your
[ __ ] hearts racing you because you're
like holy [ __ ] man like and then we wear
light blue like canvas uniforms kind of
deal and it's just like there's no blue
left it's all but all right it's all red
yeah Oh like I've seen that happen yeah
it's just like I've seen all everything
like you would see in a show or a movie
yeah but it doesn't happen all the time
I got that yeah because most people are
just trying to chill I mean like you got
a little bit of freedom yeah you're not
really trying to [ __ ] that up and grow
to confinement to where right because
you are always [ __ ] hungry in there
and like being able to hit that
commissary window is like is everything
there lie everything they do if they
ever took commissary out of prison I I
would out to kill out of killed
everybody they killed myself do that's
all you got I mean you got to think
about it like people were getting fights
over [ __ ] ramen noodles oh yeah
it's it doesn't matter it's like that's
the whole thing yeah it's the [ __ ]
principle but it's like it's just fun to
get down to that panties it's a goddamn
suit man effect do you really want to
[ __ ] die over a [ __ ] soup like
it's like I try to explain it people are
like what's it like I'm like it's really
gay and just like a whole other like
subculture of a subculture really gay
really gay yeah why yeah they do that a
lot of people think that is your Appa
soap really if you're gay for this day
it's okay because you're not on the
street like I've heard conversations
like that and it's just yeah
oh the silk droppin a for the stay gay
for the stay yeah some people are
they're okay with being gay in prison oh
I know I've also oh as I say leave it
okay this is a funny one
this is a real funny one um so I'm
laying I was at poll like I probably had
like two years left and you know like
sometimes you're just you're just
[ __ ] over everybody you can never get
away from anybody yeah I'm in a two-man
cell I'm laying on my bunk in the next
cell next to me uses like there's these
three guys talking there he's like how
am i gay [ __ ] he was sucking my
dick he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] and then
I think like the same conversation it's
like nah man he's gay he's like he's gay
gay he's like gay on the street gay like
that's like kind of the mentality I
don't know I don't got no pride I don't
got no problem I mean it just sounds
kind of [ __ ] to even say but it's a sec
this is [ __ ] this [ __ ] people like it's
the things that you tell yourself to get
through what you need right because yeah
just like the reasoning people have for
doing [ __ ] in the prison scene it
doesn't make sense to is it make sense
people like that are outside it's even
for me it didn't really make sense
because I was like just logical just
like logically thinking about stuff was
just like yeah
right you got your dick sucked by a dude
well I'm not even like yeah but that
aside for just like the way I mean but a
lot of people just I mean that's just
like a mental thing like you're you are
traumatized but nobody would admit that
in there yeah about about that but
people you know you're mine you're mine
makes helps you get through it and some
people just do weird [ __ ] [ __ ] while
they're in there yeah stories that you
need to tell yourself to justify cope
with in your actions and your coping
yeah because you have nothing else to do
in there and I think there's no human
affection other than the people that are
around you and if that's what you need
to do to get by then that's what you
need to do to get by yeah but that's
that's all that but yeah that's that's
all good but it's like people were just
just like the reasonings of like I would
hear people reason about just every
little aspect of the hole right they're
coming up with a reason for everything
for everything is there one thing that
happened in the entire like one part of
the entire experience is to sticks out
to you as like a [ __ ] up thing ever
really [ __ ] it bothered me was um okay
when I first went in and like child
molesters and [ __ ]
mmm Florida is so [ __ ] I would [ __ ]
with these dudes so bad people would I
remember getting on top of this one dude
he was in his bed like I would call mom
and ask because people like always a
child he's a chomo or whatever so but I
went oh yeah so I wouldn't know that for
sure I would call my mom I'll call my
mom a lot of times even if I was hanging
out with somebody mm-hmm I call my mom
tell her look him up okay like so I know
what they're in there for okay so cuz
it's like I do not want to be [ __ ]
hanging out with the cha Melissa right
right somebody like did some really
[ __ ] up like we all did [ __ ] up [ __ ]
but for you to like do that dick was it
was it easy to kind of figure out who
did what kind of yeah some people were
and then I remember this one dude I got
on I got on he was he was taking a nap I
I just went on top of him put my elbow
and his throat he woke up and then I
forgot had a big mouthful of skull and I
[ __ ] spit it all in his face and then
I slap I got up he just looked at me it
was just like well this [ __ ] sucks
even I can say nothing you know what I
mean because it's like half those
[ __ ] know man like it's [ __ ]
in like people a couple of times when I
would do it people people would like try
to fight me but it's not like they would
just talk [ __ ] it's not actually trying
to fight me kind of deal like that but
just for you to stick up for somebody
like that I don't know I know I didn't
know he was a chomo they all knew they
did but a lot of people will cut some
people will stick up for those guys
because if they buy on my commissary and
show yeah but you kind of like selling
your soul to the devil so it's like [ __ ]
I don't know I just don't I just don't
get it you could so you would call she
would look him up oh no you can yeah
yeah I would do that for you though yeah
cuz it was like there was a few people I
got like hung out with I mean yeah shout
out to mom [ __ ]
ended up kind of like right what
Florida's Florida is [ __ ] do you like in
every aspect of Florida not even not the
prison by Florida is a hellhole but for
every aspect of Florida it is it's
[ __ ] nobody gives a [ __ ] about
anything nobody nobody's like no morals
you there's few people are true to what
they do yeah really give a [ __ ] and I
think it's just from everybody moving
here there's no back like there's no
background yeah I mean like you go to
New York or you go to Pennsylvania like
there's generations and generations
right exactly
yeah I mean but like yeah it's like no
one's everybody there's just a Floridian
it's a bunch as this is a bunch of rich
[ __ ] white people [ __ ] up this
whole [ __ ] state bunch of rich white
people and a bunch of Aiken addicts
making all the laws
[Laughter]